[MUSIC]
We talk a lot about networks.
Most people don't have any idea how
big their networks in fact really are.
Your networks are enormous.
I mean, you start with the people in the
room, you start with everybody they know.
You start with people that they know.
You look at graduates of Stanford,
people that they know,
the places that they've worked.
Before you know it,
you can define your network literally as
being hundreds of thousands of people.
Because anybody who can make a connection
to somebody that might be willing to help
you, is in fact part of your network.
And you may not even know who they are,
but they're part of your network and
you can make that work for you.
If you want to meet somebody,
somebody, usually somebody in
the Stanford Business School alumni, Kim
Marie will make that introduction for you.
If you can figure out the right
way to get to him and
the right way to ask that question.
GSB alums will usually help.
I'll make this point because
I always make it and that is,
almost anybody is going to
be willing to help you.
I'd be willing to help you, your
classmates would be willing to help you.
Your professors and
alumni will be willing to help you, but
very few of them are going to be
willing to do your homework for you.
And so, an example,
if you call me and say,
Tom, I want to get into,
I don't know, venture capital.
Would you introduce me to
some venture capitalists?
What?
That's a lazy question, okay?
But if you said, I've got two years
in the venture capital industry,
and I'm working on a project
that Josh Greene and
More David Dahl is a board member of.
I know you know Josh, because I
know you work with him on a board.
Would you be willing to
introduce me to Josh Greene so
that I can have a conversation about this
project that I know he's interested in?
Now, night and day, those two questions.
The first one general,
requires work on my part.
And I'm not going to go do a lot of work
to try to figure out what you could have
figured out and didn't.
But the second one, if I believe that
that's a very credible question,
it takes me about 30 seconds to pop
off an email to Josh and say, look,
this is somebody I think
you ought to meet.
And they've specifically picked you out
of the hundreds or thousands of venture
capital people because of your
experience in this company.
And they're interested in that and
they think they have something to add,
would you meet with them for
15 to 20 minutes?
Specific on the one hand,
general on the other hand.
They said pick specific targets,
make specific requests.
And then if somebody does you a favor,
particularly somebody that didn't have
any reason to do it other than
they were just trying to help you.
After the thing is done,
you met with Joshua Hunter, go back,
send them an email and
tell him what happened.
Hey, I met with Josh,
thanks for setting that up.
I'm not sure what's going to come out
of it, but I really appreciate it,
we're going to stay in touch, thank you.
Believe me, that will pay dividends later.
First of all, it's just good common
courtesy if somebody did something for
you that they didn't have
to do to call them up and
thank them and tell them what happened
because they're probably curious.
It also leaves that door open to go
back to them again in the future because
they've got a good feeling about you.
This is somebody that
handled that right and
they'd be willing to go do another
favor for you down the road.
Whereas I've got a lot of people, I won't
name them, maybe I will later a few,
but who seems like every couple
of years would call me up and
say, Tom, it's been so
long since we've talked.
I really wanted to get back to you and
see how you were doing.
Well, I'm doing fine.
[LAUGH] How are you doing?
Well, I'm getting work out of looking for
a job.
Well, what happened with the last thing
that you called me about two years ago
that he never came back and
told me what happened about that?
And maybe I'll be polite to him,
maybe I won't.
More likely they don't,
somehow I'm out of town or something when
that call comes in and my EA just handles
it, it never sees the light of day.
Stay connected to the people
who've helped you.
[MUSIC]